how to preprocess pairs of sentences
we have seen how to recognize single
sentences and patch them together
in the batching inputs together video if
this code looks unfamiliar to you
be sure to check that video again here
we'll focus on tasks that classify pairs
of sentences
for instance we may want to classify
whether two texts are paraphrases or not
here is an example taken from the crore
question belts dataset
which focuses on identifying duplicate
questions
in the first spur the two questions are
duplicate
and the second permanent another
classification
problem is when we want to know if two
sentences are logically related or not
a problem called natural language
inference or nli
in this example taken from the
multi-analy data set
we have a pair of sentences for each
possible label contradiction
network or entailment which is a fancy
way of saying the first sentence
implies the second so classifying pairs
of sentences
is a problem worth studying in fact
in the glue benchmark which is an
academic benchmark for text
classification
eight of the ten data sets are focused
on tasks using pairs of sentences
that's why models like pert are often
retrained with a dual objective
on top of the language modeling
objective they often have an objective
related to sentence pairs
for instance during per training that is
shown pairs of sentences
and must predict both the value of
randomly masked tokens
and whether the second sentence follows
from the first or not
fortunately the tokenizer from the
transformers library
has a nice api to deal with pairs of
sentences
you just have to pass them as two
arguments to the tokenizer
on top of the input ids and the
attention mask we studied already
it returns a new field called token type
ids
which tells the model which tokens
belong to the first sentence
and which ones belong to the second
sentence
zooming in a little bit here are the
input ids aligned with the tokens we
correspond to
respective token type id and attention
mask
we can see the tokenizer also added
special tokens so we have a cls token
the tokens from the first sentence a
step token
so to confirm the second sentence and a
final step token
if we have several pairs of sentences we
can tokenize them together
by passing the list of first sentences
then the list of second sentences
and all the keyword arguments we studied
already like patting equal to
zooming in as a result we can see how
the tokenizer added padding
to the second pair of sentences to make
the two outputs the same length
it also properly dealt with token type
ids and attention mass for the two
sentences
this is then all ready to pass through
our model
you